right now another big story we are
covering Saudi Arabia's as a major power
play by the country's crown prince is an
effort to crack down on corruption
Mohammed bin Salman ordered the arrest
of dozens of powerful Prince's ministers
and investors some are his rivals in the
royal family a billionaire investor with
major stakes and American companies was
also taken into custody
Time magazine once declared Prince Allah
we'd been Intel the Warren Buffett of
Arabia Margaret Brennan is traveling
with the president in Tokyo Margaret
good morning good morning well it was a
political earthquake in Saudi Arabia a
place where changes often slow moving
yet in a single weekend the crown prince
removed some of the country's most
influential figures as he dramatically
reshapes that kingdom are you Joss
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman vowed
to hold accountable the kingdom's most
powerful he ordered the detention of
influential Royals including one of the
world's richest men investor Prince
Alwaleed bin Talal the economy minister
was also dismissed as well as the head
of the National Guard who led one of the
few security service branches not
already under the crown prince's control
why connect the anti-corruption campaign
if that's what it is to the removal of
the commander of the National Guard
thomas Lippmann is with the Middle East
Institute I think this is designed to
send a message which they've been
sending louder and louder for the past
several months that you will get with
the program and one man is in charge the
actions consolidate power into the hands
of 32 year old Mohammed bin Salman who
is next in line to the Saudi throne he
has been praised by the Trump
administration for his efforts to
modernize the kingdom as the purge was
under way the White House remained
silent and refused to say whether
Trump's son-in-law Jared Kushner had
discussed it during a recent visit while
flying to Asia President Trump spoke
with the crown prince's father King
Salman he said he pitched a financial
transaction valued at several hundred
billion dollars urging him to take Saudi
oil giant Aramco public in the US on the
New York Stock Exchange or Nasdaq they
also discussed another extraordinary
event
that coincided would be arrests that was
a very rapidly moving missile shot out
of this guy that was a needle in this
guy a close call with a missile shot
toward Riyadh Airport launched from
neighboring war-torn Yemen both the
president and Saudi authorities have
blamed Iran for giving those missiles to
rebels in Yemen of course it was the
Saudi Crown Prince who began that
military campaign in in Yemen and the
president has given his unwavering
support despite mass casualties there
Gayle boy thank you very much Margaret
I've heard this described as a game of
Thrones move is it yeah I don't watch
Game of Thrones I haven't seen yet I
know like that I think he's just
consolidating power I mean as the crown
prince and but it's it's there's reports
that the ritz-carlton there in Riyadh is
essentially holding many of the Matic
community yeah that's where it is it's
look at what happened in China yes a
better guide yeah to be continued for
sure